everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round
10 of our coverage of 2017 u.s. chess
championships there's only 11 around in
this tournament we could potentially
have a tiebreaker but we are in round 10
today our competitors whites going to be
played by yellow stars edible and blacks
going to be played by nakamura you know
yeah slots played pretty well you know I
think he was maybe expecting to do a
little bit better Nakamura it's had some
ups and downs he really needs a lot of
luck to go his way needs to win this
game win tomorrow and then have every
competitor above him to lose just for
him to tie so a lot of things definitely
have to go his way but he's in the
running so mathematically still
potentially could win this tournament
we're going to get started with white
pawn to e4 pawn c6 pawn to d4 and then
pawn to d5 so getting into the cuddle
con they decided to go after Knight to
c3 into the classical line so pawn takes
on e4 then after Knight to e4 then
Bishop down to to f5 and ahead you know
he could have played the classical
variation could have instead of play
Knight to d7 the modern variation so had
some options there but after Bishop to
f5 Knight back to g3 kicking the bishop
back and the Knight to h3 and this was
somewhat surprising Knight to h3 don't
see this too often the main line which
were used to seeing is pawn to h4
getting ready to push forward a little
bit more and then pawn age 6 opening up
for the bishop to come back here to age
7 and then Knight to f3 normal
development move getting it controlling
the center the board getting your knight
involved getting ready to bring your
light square bishop is involved into the
game night here to d7 pushing the pawn
up bishop comes back here to age 7 and
then Bishop to d3 there's kind of ways
to move for blacks he brings it back
here at 87 and then it's almost forced
to just exchange on board Queen to d3
usually going to get the dark square
Bishop involved into the game castle on
the Queen side since his pawn is pushed
up a little further on the King side of
the board this is a little bit difficult
in the endgame for white to hold on to
his pawn structure but that's kind of
what black is going for but as we talked
about that's not what y'all decide to do
instead play knight here to H
interesting move from him definitely a
novel variation in this opening night to
f6 and then Knight to f4 so this is what
he was looking to do is attack this
Bishop right here recognizing that the
bishops go in the fall no real way to
hold on to it now plays Knight to a d7
and he could if you wanted to go ahead
and take the bishop right now he still
has the double bishop pair pawn takes on
g6 they're opening up for a semi open
file force rook to attack on the h-file
Bishop to c4 attacking the square here
on f7 Knight over here to b6 attacking
that Bishop comes back here to b3 nice
little square that Bobby Fischer used to
really like his bishop Iran b3 decided
not to instead of you know attacking and
exchanging here on a g6 instead plays
Bishop here to c4 Nakamura continues to
Development Queen to c7 opening up the
door for a possibility to castle on the
Queen side also just wants to put a
little pressure on his opponents castle
on the kingside pond east six opening up
for the dark square Bishop get involved
into the game and then pawn to c3
solidifying the pawn chain I thought
this was enough another opportunity that
you know if he kind of looks at this and
says let's take here on g6 take back
pawn takes on g6 usually this is going
to say I'm not going to castle on the
Kings side if anything I'm going to
castle on the Queen side but it could
stay in the center of the board but
knowing that your opponent may cast on
the Queen side now then automatically
you just play pawn to a4 start pushing
on the Queen side aboard you already
have King side saves you just start
telling everything at your opponent but
besides yet again not to take here on g6
but you know I guess he just really
wanted his nights here on f4 after he
played that initial night here to h3 so
we see pawn to c3 solidifying the pawn
chain Bishop here to d6 Queen up here to
f3 both the bishop and the Queen
attacking the knight so now he has both
his Bishop and Queen defending that
night upon the c5 trying to blow up the
center of the board we do see an
exchange I think this is a good trade
for Nakamura
does get rid of the central square for
whites white has no more central squares
he does have a very very active the ship
here on c5 as vision comes back here to
AB III and then castle on the Queen side
so Nakamura had two options he had the
safe option that's guests on the Kings
side or he had the aggressive option
castle on the Queen side now I think
this is one of those situations where if
this was game 1 he may have chose
something else but know that this is
game 10 and he has to have a victory
that he's going to be as aggressive as
possible so decides to go ahead and take
our castle on the Queen side and then
now Knight takes on g6 and this is
interesting you know way to go about
this wait till your opponent castles on
the Queen side and then you know we can
the King side a little bit I think there
is a opportunity to maybe almost force
your opponent to castle on the Kings
side and then do this or to do this and
then immediately start attacking on the
Queen side but nonetheless here we are
pawn takes on g6 Bishop to f4 so
completing a development now I can start
to get his rooks involved into the game
this is attacking the Queen right here
pawn to e5 you know forcing the bishop
back Bishop back here to e3 and then
pawn to e4 now attacking the Queen
forcing him to figure out where he needs
to go with that Queen now if you want
you can kind of pause the thing about
where white really needs to play
probably the best move is Queen to f4 no
his opponent could start to attack they
can just come up here to Queen to g5
still put pressure on his opponent but I
think this is fine allows him to you
know take back here on g3 if his
opponent wants to exchange on the board
he chose a different line and definitely
a mistake in the game he played Queen to
e - he's playing way too defensive and
he's not really defending this quarters
he needs to because after the bishop
takes on e3 he takes back with his queen
now if he does take with his pawn it's
it's pretty bad as well we'll kind of
look at that and look at the variation
that he did take because then now rook
over here to h2 you know if the King
were to take work over here to H a just
putting more pressure King here to G 1
and then Queen
takes on a g3 we could see the brook
take up on f6 Knight takes on f6 Bishop
to f7 but you can see Black has a better
position going into the in game a lot of
pressure is putting on his opponent next
move can bring his knight into the
action although this is going to be a
good in game for black in the game he
probably even chose a worse line than
taking with this pawn he took with this
Queen right here and now
rook takes on h2 and the King can't take
it then Knight down to g4 check forking
the Queen the queen is going to fall
right away so can't do that so after the
rook takes on h2 he tries rook over here
to d1 you know that's that's an option
but this is this is all looking bad for
white right now because rook to h8
threatening threatening a lot of
pressure on his opponent Queen takes on
a 7 so you know starting to put pressure
it can bring his Queen over here to a8
force his opponent played Knight to b8
then he can get his rooks involved into
the game he can get his lights for a
bishop involved into the game if he
wants to and then pawn to e3 and it kind
of had two options could have played
pawn to e3 you could have played Knight
to g4 you know adding more pressure but
decides for pawn to e3 getting ready for
pawn takes on F to check you know I
think why it's kind of committed here to
just playing Queen to a eight and then
Knight to b8 rook up here to d4 trying
to get something going he saw this as
begin of a threat to go ahead and bring
his Queen down here and take on e3 but I
think this also was a mistake because
after Knight down here to g4 light was
forced to resign and we'll kind of look
at you know the different variations the
biggest threat is you know we have rook
down here to h1 check the Knights forced
to take that rope down here and then
Queen to h2 that is the mating threat
right here but if we come back and say
you know what if you tried King to f1 ok
well then the Queen is going to fall we
can see that that's going to be an easy
in game for black if we look at and say
what other option
does he have he still has to worry about
that mate threat so he could just throw
his queen away on ei to try to get rid
of that rook over here to e8 yes he's
not going to be able to mate right away
but he just lost his Queen for no reason
so at the end of the day there was
nothing white could really do so
Nakamura does the first thing he had to
do is get a win he does need three
people above him to all lose tomorrow
and if you kind of been keeping up with
the standings we have a three-way tie at
the top we have Alex on a shock we have
Wesley so in vada coat a Cobian all of
those are tied none of them play each
other so there is that and all three of
those players do have the black pieces
going into the final round 11 so
Nakamura he can get a victory and
somehow pi if things go his way but it
should be an exciting last day if we do
have a tie then we will have a tie
breaker on Monday so make sure you check
back tomorrow for round 11 but thanks
for watching this was a shorter one but
not more two extremely good job of
dismantling his opponent in this opening
few miscalculations I think on white
part Binaca Maura did very very good to
take advantage of that so thanks for
watching see you guys next video